über die letzten jahre habe ich auf
youtube immer wieder krank in gaming und
streaming setups gesehen wo wir gerade
unser neues büro im baum habe ich mich
dazu entschlossen einen raum genau dafür
zu verwenden um ein streaming setup
komplett selber zu bauen viel spaß mit
ich habe in 72 stunden gut mein traum
streaming set abgebaut
[Musik]
jetzt willkommen zu meinem traum
streaming
und natürlich nicht dass hier ist alles
was ich so zum streamen benötige oder
was sich zu hause hatte ein rechner um
ein gespräch wissen hackintosh deswegen
ist das apple logo drauf also da läuft
auch mac als betriebssystem kann ich
beim booten auswählen benutzer aber fast
windows bevor wir uns darum kümmern
machen wir erst den ganzen raum fertig
und dann kümmern wir uns im detail um
das streaming setup um das zum
minimalistischen und kleinsten setup zu
machen was wir hier gesehen habt oder
zumindest ich je gesehen habe die wand
die ich gestern gestrichen absieht
eigentlich ziemlich gut aus dass sie mit
der streaming hintergrund hier wird der
schlange zu stehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
music store wo ich jetzt aber gerade
sehe das hier direkt ein bauhaus ist
könnte ich muss schauen ob ich wieder
nicht direkt den stream hintergrund dort
bekommen denn den gibt es bei boys jetzt
erstmal music store akustik panels
[Musik]
ich konnte es wieder nicht aushalten
anderthalb wochen darauf zu warten dass
tobi wieder kommt wenn ab so ein
tatendrang mit dem büro aber auch so
allgemein dass ich irgendwie die finger
nicht davon lassen kann deswegen bin ich
nach dem music store und nachher jetzt
auch in den bau ins bauhaus gefahren und
habe die vertäfelung gekauft die ich mir
für den streaming raum gewünscht habe
das ist eine akustik vertäfelung mit
holz sieht super schön aus und ist so da
muss man schon sagen so dass standard
ding was man gerade irgendwie in
modernen wohnungen und so findet ich
freue mich dabei sehr drauf und werde
jetzt wieder eine nachtschicht einlegen
und das ding durch ballern ist 1952
wahrscheinlich bin ich nicht vor ein
oder zwei aus dem büro aus wird aber
geil dass ihr mal seht wie wirklich so
der arbeitsalltag von mir aussieht welt
das ist de facto nicht nur so wenn ich
das büro im bau sondern ich bin jeden
abend bis 22 23 uhr im büro um die ganze
scheiße die vor wie hinter der kamera
überall anfällt in irgendeiner weise zu
bewerkstelligen ohne dafür fünf weitere
leute einzustellen deswegen wird jetzt
weiter geballert ich freue mich sehr und
ich hoffe dass zumindest der raum von
akustik und verteidigung heute noch
verziert also was ist jetzt heute noch
dazu gekommen ich war losgefahren um nur
eine sache bei ikea und ein bisschen
schaumstoff zu holen ich bin losgefahren
für diesen fuß das ist der
höhenverstellbare fuß für mein setup und
für diesen schaumstoff das ist paso
texas stoff so ziemlich das krasseste
was man für sound haben kann hat man im
alten büro auch ist megageil gucke ich
das mal an wenn ihr sowas sucht davon
nicht gerade wenig für 700 euro
schaumstoff gekauft damit wir den raum
in irgendeiner weise dicht bekommen weil
ich dann aber schon mal im music star
war habe ich noch ein bisschen rum
geguckt und ich konnte nicht die finger
von lassen eine sache die ich mir schon
ganz lange kaufen wollte unglaublich
gute monitoring lautsprecher neumann
berlin ist so ziemlich das krasseste was
man kaufen kann für mikrofone und
lautsprecher kam der typ der der mir das
verkauft hat war auch richtig begeistert
also natürlich weil er ist begeistert
davon ich war aber genauso begeistert
heute das schon ganz lange haben damit
können wir den sound der videos jetzt
deutlich besser ab mission das kommt im
streaming setup mit rein weil das auch
der raum mit dem besten sound wird der
werden wir was machen werden die freunde
bekannte irgendwer bestimmt auch mal
locker aufnehmen erwartet nichts von mir
keine angst ja das wirklich geil und
damit wir das sound hoffentlich deutlich
besser klingen als er jetzt gerade tut
weil dieser raum so riesengroß ist neben
dem music stores aber direkten bauhaus
und ich konnte nicht die finger davon
lassen ich habe direkt ein streaming
hintergrund gekauft eine komplette
holzvertäfelung insgesamt 15
quadratmeter habe ich glaube ich gekauft
das seht ihr unten richtig geil das
werde ich probieren heute noch an zu
bringen und den schaumstoff auch noch
wir haben jetzt 20 uhr 30 also sollte
ich im besten fall ein bisschen weniger
reden und einfach machen aber wenn das
alles klappt dann steht der raum heute
da müssen wir uns morgen nur noch um das
wirkliche setup kümmern um den
schreibtisch um die lautsprecher und den
ganzen witzigen part jetzt erstmal
schaumstoff an die decke und
verzweiflung an die wand
hinter dem holz auch so filz haben und
dadurch auch akustik panel sind hallo
hallo ja funktioniert sehr gut
hoffentlich
klein surft wird
die sind richtig geil
[Musik]
gar nicht mal anderthalb stunden sind
wir komplett durch mit holzvertäfelung
das ging jetzt wirklich super easy von
der hand im prinzip halten festschrauben
ein bisschen zu schneiden und das ging
nicht nur einfach von der hand sondern
bezieht unglaublich gut aus also
wirklich das hier so ziemlich genau das
wird mein streaming hintergrund werden
natürlich kommt noch pflanzen hin aber
ich bin sehr happy damit mich genauso
wie meine streamings daraus sehen
wahrscheinlich genauso wichtig wichtig
genau so dass man die weißen wände seite
die holzvertäfelung war aber nicht die
einzige museum heute abend es muss noch
barbar sonntag an die wände beim letzten
mal habe mir das komplett freestyle
einfach so an die wände geklebt das war
ich diesmal nicht hört das schön mit
einer wasserwaage zeichnet genau an wo
sie hinkommt genau 17 platten auf den
fußboden wird wahrscheinlich komplett
über die komplette breite in teppich
kommen den ich schon habe damit es von
unten nach oben einfach weniger halt
aber ich merke jetzt schon dass wir
nicht hier rein spreche ist deutlich
besser ist als wenn ich im offenen raum
sprechen wenn man es schon 23 uhr 10 und
dann ist der abend für heute gelaufen
ganz katastrophen einmal hier einmal
hier dreimal nach oben dreimal hier
dreimal hier dreimal hier drei mal hier
ein nur 32 wir sind fertig es ist
unglaublich wahrscheinlich hört ihr auch
den riesigen unterschied schon überall
um mich herum hängt schaumstoff alles
abgemessen ist es vielleicht an manchen
stellen nicht auf den millimeter gerade
aber zumindest funktioniert und es
funktioniert richtig gut das hört ihr
wahrscheinlich und das wird man
definitiv märkten überall hinter mir
hängt in entweder schaumstoff oder jetzt
diese holzvertäfelung also wirklich
überall außer an den decken und der
boden muss noch gemacht werden also es
ist noch nicht mal so sound wie es wird
richtig geil das heute aber noch
durchgezogen zu haben weil wir uns dann
morgen direkt um das streaming setup an
sich kümmern können also neubau umbau
einbau von neuen streaming setup das
endlich so machen wie ich es immer haben
wollte geiles kabelmanagement alles
irgendwie so versteckt höhenverstellbar
aber das seht ihr morgen nachdem wir
jetzt noch einmal in zehn vergleichen
12 gerade
das hier ist der sound nach dem umbau
mit base takt sound est 1 23
man merkt schon auf das aus der tür raus
geht und in diesen riesigen raum rein
halt aber es ist viel besser viel viel
besser eine sache wir werden hier in
diesem raum natürlich auch unsere
gesamten boys aufnehmen was in max in
meinen videos ja ziemlich häufig
passiert jetzt guck mal was passiert
wenn man zehn ecke bewegen und das ist
nicht mal einen großen brand mikrofon
sondern das ganz normale mikrofon auf
meiner kamera in einem land vor unserer
zeit wenn wir jetzt noch einen großen
membran mikrofon benutzen dann wird es
absolut cars was euch sagen die von mir
eigens angefertigte platte passt nicht
siehst du kurz ich hab mir lautsprecher
gekauft die sollen mit auf den tisch
damit sie hoch und runter mitfahren
können damit ich den sound den guten
sound auch im stehen haben kann die
platte ist zu kurz deswegen musste ich
losfahren neue platte kaufen größere
platte kaufen und die müssen jetzt
wieder bearbeiten schleifen ziehen und
dieses mal nicht lackieren sondern in
der holz farbe die auch an der wand ist
wird auch jetzt meine arbeitsplatte
[Musik]
es funktioniert ich habe einen
höhenverstellbaren tisch in meinem
streaming zimmer und der sieht
folgendermaßen aus
unglaubliche tisch geht komplett genau
über die länge aber so dass wir den an
dem biotech vorbei noch hoch und
runterfahren können werden die komplette
fläche genutzt ich bin superhappy das
holz mit nicht 100 prozent mit dem hier
aber das okay ist besser als diese
anthrazit und die platte ist eben größer
so dass wir jetzt und morgen komplett
ums richtige setup kümmern können ihr
kommen drei bildschirme hin direkt
daneben drankommen die boxen hier vorne
auch noch mal eine box im endeffekt soll
ein kabel hoch zum schreibtisch gehen
der rechner soll unter dem tisch gemacht
werden also so dass man ähnlich sieht
die ps 5 auf und so ziemlich alles so
dass der tisch quasi eine einheit ist
und da werden wir uns morgen darum
kümmern muss leider erst noch trocknen
und dann können wir morgen endlich
weiter machen und hoffentlich das ganze
jetzt finalisieren ich habe den ganzen
tag damit verschwendet hin und
herzufahren darauf zu warten dass es
irgendwie an trocknet und die beine
machen können jetzt bin ich aber
das allerwichtigste war für mich das
streaming setup von vornherein richtig
zu planen das sollte super
minimalistisch sein ich wollte nicht
dass man kabel sieht und es musste eben
vernünftig höhenverstellbar sein würde
ich den rechner und gps fünf
beispielsweise auf den boden stellen
müssen die kabel lang genug sein um den
fisch hoch und runter fahren zu können
deswegen habe ich mich dazu entschlossen
die ps 5 und den rechnern direkt am
tisch festzumachen an der tischplatte
dafür brauchte ich ein paar neue
accessories also halterungen für pc und
playstation die ich am tisch festmachen
kann tatsächlich hatte ich das vorher
noch nie irgendwo gesehen und musste mir
das selber überlegen hat aber eigentlich
ganz gut funktioniert das grundkonzept
meinen schreibtisch steht jetzt ein
bildschirm montiert während unten strom
und so schon drunter liegen die
lautsprecher müssen darauf die kameras
installiert wenn das licht muss
installiert werden super viel kram der
jetzt noch mit greenback muss noch hin
headset tastatur maus es gibt noch eine
menge zu tun das machen aber im raum
damit ich gleich nicht alles mit super 4
kam dran übertragen muss und dann wird
hoffentlich das streaming setup final
zusammengebaut und dann kann ich gleich
direkt
[Musik]
die machen kleinen screen testfahrzeug
morgen in den urlaub und jetzt werde ich
eine woche nicht von hier stream können
aber ich kann es nicht abwarten
zumindest die leute auf tweets sollten
schon sehen dass sie in nächster zeit
set mäßig erwartet und er sollte auch
auftritt vorbei schauen erst der link in
der video beschreibung da ist für mich
ab und zu
ein onkel perfekt
willkommen aus dem neuen stream studio
[Musik]
vier tage vollgas jeden abend bis spät
in die nacht durch gebühren mit hat sich
absolut ausgezahlt habe mir meinen
eigenen streaming raum mein traum
streaming raum selber gebaut und das von
vorne bis hinten die wände selber
gemacht die akustik selber gemacht die
paneele selber gemacht die einrichtung
mir selber überlegt das konzept für den
schreibtisch selber überlegt das habe
ich tatsächlich vorher noch nie irgendwo
gesehen dass alles an den tisch
festzumachen bin mit dem ergebnis mehr
als zufrieden es gibt natürlich immer
noch eine menge zu tun fertig wird das
erst über den prozess wenn man merkt
hier fehlt was da fehlt was oder das
könnte man auch ändern vielen dank dass
ihr das video bisher angeschaut habt ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen und ich
konnte irgendwie ein bisschen
inspiration für euer eigenes setup
mitnehmt wir sehen uns in den nächsten
tagen wieder vergesst nicht zu
abonnieren cous cous cous
[Musik]